ja den deutschen buchpreis 2009 10 für
den roman des jahres verleiht die
stiftung kultur und leseförderung des
börsenvereins des deutschen buchhandels
an seine welt heiß entscheidung ist
etwas das liegt er auf dem herzen auf
der leber was ist da passiert
ja es ist es ist dass uns etwas passiert
unglaublich eigentlich dass jemand den
preis bekommen hat der der ist in meinen
augen gibt nicht verdient hat und zwar
nicht wegen allgemein wegen
literarischer qualität muss man eben
wegen dessen was und wie er das gemacht
hat und das habe ich jetzt auch gerade
eine rede gesagt ich will einfach gehört
werden dass ich mir auch nicht der
einzige der das sagt der das nicht in
ordnung findet viel literatur von peter
handke instrumentalisiert wird in
welcher art und weise er über gerade
über dem bosnien krieg gesprochen hat
und deswegen war es mir wichtig dass ich
das wirklich auf mehreren kanälen sage
jetzt bin ich aber auch jetzt habe ich
nicht wieder eingekriegt sascha stanicic
reißt den herkunft und seinen geburtsort
an die drina in visegrad bosnien zu
seiner großmutter deren erinnerung mehr
einfängt
zurück in whistler auf ihren teams das
in den 90er jahren auseinander fällt
nationalismus und krieg zwingen die
familie zur flucht über eine grenze die
heute geschlossen ist
also ich drehe mich um und sehe okay
dass das sind leute die dann diese dinge
auch wirklich lesen und das ding
probiere ich mich auch aus und schaut
wie es in der reaktion das heißt ich bin
mir der leserschaft im moment der
entstehung des fettes bewusst und das
ist komisch gehen
dies spornte nicht dass an ich mache
manchmal auch eine offene dokument
online und lasse leuten kommentieren was
sie da gerade mache und es ist wie eine
wm wäre so eine kleine interne deadline
eigentlich ich will die leute für die
zeit die ich mir dann gebe für die paar
stunden mit etwas auch beliefern also
ich will ihnen was gäbe und dass das
wort miteinander an schlechten tagen
wirklich wichtig dass ich dann jemanden
haben der mir über die schulter geguckt
und das hat dazu geführt dass manche
texte die ich da auf twitter geschrieben
haben oder in solchen offenen dokumenten
später eingang gefunden haben
das buch und andere die in einem buch
aus und ähnliche pointierte kurze form
hatten in diesem feld auch in twitter
übergeschwappt sind also das ist eine
wechselwirkung wie ich total furchtbar
findet meine arbeit hast du denn auch
schon sachen nicht geschrieben oder
wieder rausgeschmissen weil es zu wenig
gegeben hat in diesem hohlraum internet
geht also geht gar nicht um so sehr um
das echo ich habe ich mir noch den
dienst an beurteilung einnimmt oder raus
nimmt aber ja klar es gibt dinge die
dort stehen ich habe mal einen account
übernommen von dax werner twitter
legende und habe dort eine kleine
geschichte erzählt die über darüber wie
ich wo ich alles nicht verprügelt worden
bin
als es eigentlich fand sie so in dem
zusammenhang total interessant aus über
darüber nachzudenken wo ich mein glück
aber das war dann für das buch zum
beispiel kann ihn nicht in frage weil
ich dann doch irgendwie albern fand was
zählt ist aber eigentlich ist also die
apokryphen die wir dann irgendwann mal
nach genau kein konventionelles endet
nämlich mit einem text adventure was
kann das text adventure was der text
nicht kann verantwortung übergeben
eine leser genau richtig sonst muss er
das lesen was er steht oder wer gibt es
auf aber dort muss er selber gucken das
will ich das will ich nicht dass mich
das vielleicht nicht das fand ich schön